the cleanup in vervier is going to take
months this city is nicknamed the water
capital of the region
the river a really central part of its
economic life
and so when the water came it simply
wasn't prepared for the scale and the
intensity of what happened
residents are doing their best but still
reeling the infrastructure that
supported this part of their city
gone that's for everyone it's terrible
it's like the apocalypse
nami lagzawi shows us his ruined pizza
shop
oh what a mess he has no power
nothing to help him recover and reopen
big problem but what can i do
nothing everybody here
the same nearby we find a utilities
crew working to solve the problem at
their end but there's been so much
damage to the physical network
they don't know how long it will take
all the thing around here was like
quite submerged and we didn't you know
think that it was like as that bad it's
gonna be so
yeah it's quite a surprise
volunteers hand out supplies vervier is
a modern city in western europe
but days after the flood hit there's
still real need here
everything is kaput and you don't have
any fresh water in there to drink
yeah i have this
only this water one day the man
gave me and there's nothing to be found
at the local supermarket
it's in ruins the owner says it won't
reopen
it's my it's my life my money um
let's finish
still dealing with patchy mobile signals
and no internet
homeowners contemplate how quickly the
fabric of their comfortable lives was
ripped apart
did you feel like the infrastructure of
your
city was ready for when the water's gone
no no no no no
no absolutely not you know you see this
place there
it's completely broken nobody was
prepared for this
either here's the street just she's
broken everything is broken
climate change scientists warn that
events like this may happen more
frequently
unless they are better protected this
may not be the last time these residents
face
such challenges hannah thomas peter sky
news
in vervier